bonjour c'est une hérésie merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
les rebelles houthi considérée comme
terroriste par washington quelles
conséquences sur le terrain au sud de la
péninsule arabique et yade saluent cette
décision téhéran la condamnant oui
bonjour effectivement va y avoir des
impacts qui est très très rare par
rapport aux limites le fait de
considérer les outils comme com com
comme des terroristes ça va ça va ça va
attiser la situation au yémen ça va
faire tanguer davantage le bateau ou la
barque si j'ose appeler ça comme ça plus
qu'elle est en train de tanguay ça va
leur permettre aussi de justifier auprès
de la population gay men in comme quoi
il sent les là pour les aider que
l'international ne s'occupe pas d'eux ça
va leur permettre aussi de faire
davantage de recrutement dans leurs
rangs parce que les mâles va être
davantage appauvri il devrait y avoir
plus de famine doit y avoir plus de
dégâts non seulement matérielle mais et
on a plus des couloirs pour faire passer
les idées qu'ils soient des aides
humanitaires que des médicaments et de
la nourriture
donc c'est une situation c'est comme
pour moi mettre du feu sûr de lui ça ne
va pas du tout les calmer ça va donner
la possibilité à l'iran et aux outils de
de se rapprocher davantage une
population qui est complètement exténué
qui est complètement fatigué et que
davantage il trouvera ni médicaments ni
nourriture ça va donner aussi la main ou
les oignons rend la même mise
complètement sur le sort des yéménites
10 ml qui n'ont pas cette possibilité ni
de quitter le territoire
on sait que l'aéroport de sanaa est
fermée donc depuis plusieurs années donc
on ne peut pas faire partir les malades
on peut pas faire partir des délais liés
mais need et des quais qui font des
études qui sont qui ont besoin de
quitter les territoires
donc pour moi c'est un coup de vent de
nord haut lieu c'est pas pour moi une
punition mais c'est plutôt un cadeau on
ne sait pas si longtemps en vigueur
juste avant l'investiture de joe biden
que fera selon vous le nouveau président
américain
c'est triste à dire de toute façon c'est
un certain coût
médiatiquement aussi diplomatique par
rapport à train passer un clin d'oeil
qu'il renvoie aux pays du golfe pour
leur dire voilà j'ai j'ai exécuté j'ai
fait j'ai respecté nos engagements
jusqu'à la dernière minute
le problème c'est que si les rentrées en
vigueur
dell ne pourra pas s'en débarrasser tout
le monde savait tout le monde attendait
un rapprochement entre l'iran et les
états unis une situation un peu moins
complexe
non seulement au yémen mais dans tout le
moyen orient
mais on sait très bien que si on a le
doigt qui rentre en vigueur il va y
avoir plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années
si on a envie d'en mettre en place une
autre dont claire l'iran a condamné
cette décision rillettes je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure salue cette décision mais
au delà de condamner verbalement que
peut faire liron et quelles conséquences
surtout sur l'accord de vienne sur le
nucléaire iranien
de toute façon à élire on n'a plus rien
à perdre en sait que les outils ce sens
le bras de l'iran au yémen donc ça va
leur donner aussi la possibilité
maintenant ils voulaient pas être
considérés comme des terroristes
maintenant ils le sont donc aucune
législation aucune loi ne pourra leur
imposer quoi que ce soit pour l'iran il
a quand même peut-être des négociations
tout le monde est optimiste par rapport
à l'arrivée de joe biden qui lui même
dit que il va pas garder la situation
débloquée sur place peut-être il va y
avoir des parts dans des arrangements
des solutions mais pas à la hauteur de
ce que tout le monde attend et en
l'occurrence que l'iran attend aux
williams mène à mon avis la situation va
être de mauvais empire les choses ne
vont pas c'est de se débloquer pour le
moment et il faut attendre à l'outil on
dit qu'ils se réserve le droit de
riposter à cette annonce
de l'administration trump comment ils
vont le faire selon vous s'ils le font
c'est ce que j'étais en train de dire
maintenant il va y avoir des routes
présent les outils sont décidément rien
à perdre c'est pas un mouvement
idéologique c'est ancré dans la
mentalité des personnes qui suivent le
mouvement
donc ça va être vraiment les dégâts y
vont être néfastes non seulement pour le
yémen mais pour tout l'entourage et là
on parle de l'arabie saoudite en
l'occurrence peut y avoir
ça peut toucher aussi des pays
avoisinants parce que on sait très bien
que le yémen il ya les outils mais il ya
aussi les des extrémistes comme al-qaïda
comme neige
et il ya des canaux de communication qui
sont ouverts entre c'est entre tout
entre tous ces partis là
donc à mon avis qu'il faut vraiment soit
le trap décident à la dernière minute
qu'on en a l'habitude de voir de retirer
ou d'annuler la mise en place de cette
loi soit la situation va s'aggraver
le prix ça m est non seulement pour le
yémen et les mérites des ça va être
aussi la communauté internationale en
l'occurrence les pays avoisinants
merci c'est une série d'avoir répondu à
la question je rappelle que vous êtes
géopolitologue et spécialiste du yémen